[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
dude i i've made a thing as a joke when
i i uh when i tried to [ __ ] with bert
uh well i [ __ ] with him all the time but
he's your handicapped friend yeah yeah
yeah i've seen that i do a
thing without help him out put him on a
show like his whole career
no like he he has special you know
needs right right and so he's like you
know
will you work with me sounds like a
volunteer thing i bring him in
i do a podcast but like it's basically
like helping him
you know yeah yeah no no i i've seen and
a lot of people on the internet
often say uh there's a quote if you've i
don't know if you've seen it even if you
read comments but it's always said
um they call it cool charity i didn't
know what that was and it's
i guess there's a thing called cool
charity it's a it's a charity called
cool charity
and it's money to keep funding you
helping bert because they're afraid that
at some point
you'll get over it and get sick of it
yeah i think that's right i imagine you
probably feel
a certain way about bobby yeah i know uh
bobby to me
is bobby isn't my bert to you though
because to you
and bert like you there's love in your
heart for him
absolutely and with bobby it's more like
um i i i literally i hate him as a human
as a comedian and i'm doing it because
it's a debt that i owe and i
and i owe i have a i have 185 000
outstanding debt at caesars in vegas
yeah and i just got to recoup some of
that money back so this is a thing i
just need to do
uh also the state gives me 45 bucks a
month to
watch over him i have to check on him
twice a day but that's like gas money
right
yeah yeah but honestly it's it's just
troubling because when you have to you
have to wake him up you have to put him
to bed you have to clean him and
cleaning him is the hardest
do you have to clean bert no so you have
to clean bob
and washing him is tough because he
squeamish you know you got him in the
tub
yeah but they freak out he hates water
he's tubby
yes and and when he gets in there he
panics
and he doesn't like shampoo time and
when we dry him off it's tough so
it's it's a challenge but you know i'm
willing to do it yeah
i'm willing to do it because i'm a nice
guy and i do i do care about
you know not him but like maybe other
people other people yeah around him or
repaying my debts in any
in any semblance you know i like that
[ __ ] whatever ago
but this is my signature now oh look i'm
not gonna be able to do it because i'm
nervous
hold on that's my signature now
no that is what it looks like yeah yeah
so i have no idea what it's just an a
and an s
yeah but it's not an s it's a whoopty
swoop let me see it again
[Laughter]
you're not really giving a lot no i but
also
when i sign stuff when people when if i
when i used to sell like posters after
shows i would do these art these red
rocket art posters
i would sign that i would sign it this i
go like that
that okay that's that's closer david
spade that's david spade
that's david spade you signed i want to
see what yours looks like mine looks
more like by the way this was just a
ploy to get this so i could sell this
after the show
yeah this uh yours the top one is
ridiculous but that's how i sign
checks if i'm gonna sign a check i have
so i have two signatures okay give me
both
all right so they're very similar but
one is for like official things in which
i signed thomas
and then do you really sign thomas for
like banks and stuff like that wow
but uh or like you know anything that's
like like that's like
a legal thing right right so and you've
been in a lot of legal trouble lately
are you ever gonna pay back any of those
fines you you'll end up like wesley
snipes out of jail
thomas i'll show that to the kids sagura
right that's actually kind of cool
looking yeah it's not bad right no it's
not bad
and then this is the this is the um
[Music]
tom sagura let's see underneath see i
like that one a lot more yeah that one
looks a little more
it just looks cooler it's cooler it's a
lot cooler
don't this is going on the internet by
the way you guys click on the link below
at buytomsignature.com i'll be selling
this
starting bids are at 10 g's baby this is
a rarity yeah
all the all the proceeds are going to go
down i bet i did a bit
over 10 years ago on an album and it
came out
and then melanie did a like the same
topic
and he's like you know the perfect
comedian
so yeah there was like he's every all
his bits are great
so people started to hit me up this was
like a while ago like
oh cool mullany bit you did what was it
by the way it was a
[ __ ] n-word comparison i have the same
i'm doing that bit right now do it run
with it it's brand new
so i did it did you say the n-word yeah
i say it over and over and over i say
like 45
my bit is i don't say the m-word because
the m-word's offensive to me which
is uh little
i say little person i think the m word
is disgusting but the n word i'll say a
thousand times yeah yeah
i say that a bunch and then i say but
little lp i'll say yeah yeah yeah yeah i
mean this is also by the way
matching on its own level yeah this is a
match i do matchy stuff but it's because
i only have three colors
yeah i'm kind of like you people talk
about me in the comments always like oh
where
buy new clothes but i can't afford it
and people need to know that
i don't have any money to buy new
clothes i knew that yeah you know that
because you care about me but they
you know they just want to like you know
belittle me and it's like dude i can't
afford to buy new stuff so
black uh and and blue and gray is all i
can afford
once you get into like reds and yellows
greens teals all that stuff
it's expensive those are thousands of
thousands i imagine i don't know
yeah what they cost when you go i i have
a few i have a yellow shirt and i have a
teal shirt they were 2800 bucks each
a piece a piece see and that's that's
for the color it's just for the color
do you wear them ever i mean on special
occasions you know mostly
i wear black because it's free yeah
black is always well that's why i wear
these pants these are free
everything black as is free
clothing-wise everybody knows that but
one day i'll i'll get into if i mean you
know if something good happens in the
biz i'll be able to afford a yellow
or blue shirt i'd love to be there that
day i'll invite you
no okay okay what about like little
nazaks
you know no no
[Laughter]
no man burt's a sneaky athlete the way
that i used to feel about paul pierce
like paul pierce has that body
where you're like this guy's he looks
like a dude i know
like he's just bigger and kind of
slovenly yeah but he's unbelievably
athletic
bert would not surprise me on the golf
course i bet you he's very good there's
guys that i play with yeah i'm not gonna
mention names
that have dog [ __ ] dumpy awful bodies i
mean dude completely out of shape and
actually
unathletic as [ __ ] they couldn't throw a
baseball they couldn't throw a football
but out there they're phenomenal yeah
it's something about
he can dial it in for gol golf he talks
a lot of [ __ ] for everything and you're
like you can't do any of these things
but in golf if you were to be like this
matters
you need to play well he would he would
be able to yeah he's got that thing he
has that like
uh uh he's got that forever focus where
you're like well i'll just commit
everything i have to something one of my
favorite stories is uh when i was
getting to know him we went to hawaii
this is like
2008. and so i didn't really you know
we're hanging out there
doing this show together and i was like
oh do you play uh
i can't even say i go did you play
football in high school and he was like
i was supposed to be like the next great
player there but i got injured i was
like
who what what what do you mean supposed
to be what do you mean he was like no i
was like
he's like i was really good at baseball
and i was like uh-huh and then
like i was supposed to be like they were
expecting me to be like
the next like all-state player and i was
like
why would they expect that yeah he's
like because i was just like so good at
other things
but then like i hurt my shoulder and i
was like this guy
that's why they thought you were going
to be the next great thing just because
you were good at this
expectations that you'll be an amazing
athlete see this guy in layup drills
in gym class you know but you know he's
going to be in all-state football but
there's no doubt about it
how many little i mean are we going to
stop with the littles there but he's so
he like talk about being good at
reinventing himself this kid
he comes out he becomes he's got this
like the [ __ ] right
no lil nas is the is the kid oh oh
little oh you're
not the blood shoes yes yes the country
song
i like him right now i was thinking of
see another little i was thinking like
little z
vert or los angeles and he's the one
that has this yeah yeah yeah that's what
i was saying little nasdaq's is a is
dope
i think he's he's cool i like it well i
like that he comes out he makes a
non-hip hop song he makes a country song
it blows up
he's like also i'm gay yeah and they're
like oh [ __ ] yeah and then now he's in
his devil play in satanic stuff satanic
shoes yeah he's leveling up to me
i got i think the more you keep shifting
i'm in
and the fact that his satan shoes
prompted like senators
so funny come out and be like this is
the problem with america
kids putting blood in their shoes it's
it's that's what's going to ruin this
country
yeah buy guns more guns how are you
going to come up with it now now that i
think about though how ridiculous is his
name
little nas x the [ __ ] out of here stolen
stolen stolen stolen
what is that even what is that he's cool
but that name is crazy you have a
podcast that i
loved coming on um that's i should let
me redo that
you have you have a podcast that i
enjoyed being a part of
um and it's called where my mom's at and
that's that's
unbelievably it's an unbelievably funny
podcast and i can listen to it all day
thank you
it's really good it is really good and
it's uh
it's christina's that's her that's her
mom podcast
oh where my mom's at no christina's is
the
uh your mom's house no the other way no
christina's podcast is your mom's house
and well it's also hers because she
could right oh so they're both hers
well i mean yeah but that makes sense
yeah yeah those are both hers
um in nine weeks i've made pretty crazy
progress
yeah and i will lose all of it when i do
the surgery
[Music]
and also yesterday after i got my like
they they were like you have a hernia
i was like i told the doctor you never
felt anything i didn't feel it
he was like it's small but he's like
it's gonna get worse like you have to
fix it i'm like well
i tell them obviously i'm doing this
program yeah can i keep lifting he was
like
yeah he's like you can keep lifting i go
with the hernia that's what i'm saying
i'm like but
wouldn't it get worse she's like yeah
and i go
so should i keep lifting he's like i
don't know i'm a doctor dude i'm not
your friend yeah
i go well but i mean i go i'm not you
know i'm not saying i'm not a
strong man category but i'm lifting
heavy weight
i'm doing reps with 300 pounds on dead
like i'm doing reps with it that's heavy
as [ __ ]
it's pretty heavy yeah but i go and i go
and i i'm saying it feels heavy
to me it's not about like sure sure like
to me some guy feel that it is
[ __ ] dude of course so i'm like the
strain
is i go it's full body straight like i
can feel my body being like holy [ __ ]
every time i complete a set of this
right and i go and now it's going to be
in my head
that my organs are popping through
a cavity he's like yeah she's going to
have to see what happens i'm like
a little unknown stuff about you that
people don't know is you
you actually wrote the original
screenplay for hamilton for the show for
the play hamilton yeah
which i think is so annoying that that
guy took all the credit for it and
took all the royalties and took all this
oh you're not getting paid nope
that's offensive dude because that's
your play so lin manuel
and his his mom and my mom were like
friendly and they you know they used to
like spec [ __ ] together
oh cool so like when you know we got to
talking about he likes hip-hop and i was
like yeah
i do too right so we started um kind of
going back and forth and then he's like
you know
do you know anything about history and i
was like i don't think my history dude
like what do you want to know about so i
started i'm the one that gave him the
whole background on right you know like
on hamilton dude yeah so he didn't know
any of that stuff until you
nothing what a thief dude nothing he was
like we were founded in 16
i was like 16. he didn't know didn't
know the year
you know yeah what is he what is he
you know what dude but and that and when
i saw the goatee i thought that's
that's a giveaway that's a giveaway yeah
tom probably said oh why don't you shave
into a goatee because he used to have a
beard
yeah well the goatee because what
happens when you have a goatee
your lips look like an [ __ ] look it
looks like
so right i was like i know you're an
[ __ ] yeah
so you know why don't you put a goatee
on your face
god that's smart that's a smart one
just the wrong way